NARRATOR: Socialism--
socialism--
Workers to power!
NARRATOR: Socialism?
We are fighting to put
more power in the hands
of everyday working Americans.
NARRATOR: Socialism--
[music playing]
Before it became a dirty
word, socialism was relatively
popular in the United States.
So what happened?
Socialism can refer
to a whole bunch
of economic and
political philosophies
based around the
idea that communities
should either own or regulate
the means of production.
The means of production being
the facilities and resources
from raw materials to
tools and factories
used to create wealth.
Principles of
socialist societies
had already been
adopted in America
by some religious communities,
like the Amish and Shakers
in the early 19th century.
Socialism was eventually
championed by American labor
activists in the
late 19th century
as part of a new
political movement.
That was largely thanks to
German economists and writers
Karl Marx and Friedrich
Engels and their theories
about class struggle in the wake
of the Industrial Revolution.
They applied socialist theory to
a vision of communist society.
The short version
of their vision is--
in rebellion against
industrial injustice and labor
exploitation, the working
class should have a revolution
taking property and money away
from wealthy greedy business
owners and sharing it
with the entire community.
The long version
is, well, very long.
But the point is it
caught on in America,
sparking a long
tradition of socialism
and socialist thought.
The first socialist
to hold public office
in the United States was elected
as a city councilman in 1897.
The first socialist to serve
in Congress won in 1910.
In 1912, Eugene Debs
ran for president
on the socialist party ticket
and won 6% of the popular vote.
As socialism gained popularity
in the United States,
it was also gaining
popularity in Russia,
which was still an empire.
The Marxist Russian
Social Democratic
Labor Party, a radical
socialist party formed in 1898.
In 1903, a faction called
the Bolsheviks split off
founded by Vladimir Lenin
and Alexander Bogdanov,
who considered themselves
leaders of Russia's
revolutionary working class.
By 1912, the Bolsheviks
were their own party.
There were a lot of parties in
Russia over the next few years.
In 1917, the Russian
empire collapsed.
Emperor Nicholas II
abdicated the throne,
and by October, power was
given to the Soviets, groups
of grassroots workers
assemblies that identified
as socialists and communists.
By January 1918,
Vladimir Lenin had seized
control of the government.
By November, World War I had
ended, and back in America,
workers began to strike,
demanding the robust wages they
enjoyed during the war economy.
Also, in 1919, a string
of bombs targeted
at high ranking US government
officials and notable
businessmen were discovered.
Thus, began the
first Red Scare--
a heightened fear that
radicalism in the US
might lead to a violent
revolution like in Russia
and bring an end to democracy
and American values.
Paranoia surrounding the bombs
and the strike spurred attorney
general A. Mitchell Palmer to
coordinate a series of raids,
targeting thousands of people
he thought might be harboring
dangerous ideas and
who he suspected
might be communists
or anarchists.
These would be known
as the Palmer raids.
While fears of
communism lingered,
many citizens became
wary of capitalism too.
Because in 1929,
America had plummeted
into a Great Depression.
In the mid-1930s, President
Franklin Delano Roosevelt
was both criticized and
lauded for implementing
socialist leaning
policies and programs
to combat the economic crisis.
Meanwhile, in
Russia, Joseph Stalin
had risen to power by 1928,
advocating his own version
of communism combining some
socialist economic policies
with executions, deportations,
a cult of personality,
and totalitarianism.
In the 1940s, the capitalist
US and the communist USSR
maintained an alliance so
they could defeat the Nazis.
After World War II ended,
President Harry Truman
refocused his efforts on making
sure the Soviet Union did not
have too much influence abroad.
Socialism became synonymous with
the Soviets, and their version
of communism, which was
seen as a direct threat
to America's free market
capitalist system.
Worried again that a communist
revolution could happen
in the US, American leaders told
the public, again, that they
should be afraid of communism.
And by the time
Eisenhower was in office,
Americans were pretty
afraid of communism.
Between 1950 and 1954,
Wisconsin Senator Joe McCarthy,
who was also afraid
of communism,
helped to make Americans
very afraid of communism
by launching a series of highly
publicized investigations
into potential communist
infiltration in the White
House, the treasury, the State
Department, and even the army.
This second Red Scare
shaped the attitudes
of Americans towards
communism and socialism
for decades to follow.
Attitudes that would prevail
throughout the Cold War
and after the Cold War.